hey guys how's it going happy tech
tuesday yes i know it's not tuesday but
today we're going to talk about a little
bit of tech not actually that much tech
because i'm going to be doing an
unboxing of the new rose gold apple
watch it's the sport edition that they
just announced at the keynote recently
now they also announced a few other
things which i'm going to go over just
really quickly because a lot of you guys
wanted me to make a video about it and i
didn't i'm sorry i should have actually
live streamed my reactions of watching
the keynote they announced a bunch of
things they announced the new ipad pro
which will be out very soon the funny
thing about this keynote is they didn't
really give us specific dates for a lot
of things which kind of was driving me
nuts we've got new iphones the iphone 6s
and the iphone 6s plus which you can
pre-order starting saturday and it'll be
coming the end of the month i think it's
the 25th they said they also announced
an apple pencil which when they said
they had an apple pencil people were
losing their minds they're like i'm
sorry what did you just say an apple
pencil steve jobs said he would never
have a stylus but
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
this steve jobs said that the phone does
not need to have a stylus because most
of the phones and things of that time
you needed a stylus to be able to type
and to be able to interact and to
actually use the device whereas the
interface of the iphone and the os was
developed so that you would not need a
stylus to use your phone the pencil is
specifically made for the ipad pro where
artists and illustrators and people that
are taking notes and creating documents
and things like that are going to be
using the pencil it's not a stylus it's
not something that you're going to be
using every day on your phone you know
that's not what it was made for but i'm
kind of excited about it not coming from
sort of the illustrator side but i used
to be a graphic designer so that's
something that i'm kind of excited about
just to sort of see how that's being
used this is not a rant about the apple
pencil which i may or may not make a
video about it this is a video to unbox
the new rose gold
apple watch which is
what we've got in front of us right here
and it's not just a rose gold if you
were to take rose gold and take the
saturation out of the color rose you get
the color pink that's what this is
there's no gold this is gold this is
rose gold it's pink but guess what
i freaking think it looks fantastic
so if this is something that you might
be into there it is open up you look
fantastic
oh god it looks good wow it looks way
better than it looks in the store i went
to the store this morning to take a peek
at it before this one arrived the rose
gold and this
freaking
i think it's called was it like a stone
a stone color uh band if you were just
walking by and i saw you i would say hey
do you want to go to
dinner
do you want to get coffee
you look great okay let's put it on a
smaller one rose gold detailing
on
the watch band oh my god this looks good
but well i guess it's sort of rose gold
like this bracelet's not let's see
that's not like this is not this is rose
gold this is rose gold this is pink but
it's gonna look a lot better with my
outfits so
great
yeah it looks good it looks pretty good
i'm gonna say it looks good here's the
question what does the dog think
he's sleeping we're gonna let him sleep
because he's been rowdy
okay let's go set these out on the table
let's send them out
so that my friends is
the rose gold apple watch that was just
released i think it's pretty cool i
think honestly if a lot of you guys are
on the fence about getting an apple
watch i think it's one of those things
that you really might want to go to the
store check out play with and put it on
one of the things that i'm really
excited about which i completely forgot
about is they're gonna have a gopro
viewer and i use gopros all the time for
projects and shooting and filming so
being able to have that gopro viewer
right on my wrist is going to be
pretty much life-changing and i kind of
think that that's going to be a huge
seller for a lot of people because you
don't need to get the high and expensive
one to be able to use this application
all of the watches are exactly the same
the software is the same the speed is
the same so even if you're buying a more
expensive watch you're not getting any
upgrades in software so there is no need
for you guys to go out and buy the most
expensive watch grab yourself the sport
edition you can always upgrade the bands
there's tons of amazing third-party
bands that you guys can get that look
pretty cool uh i'm gonna go because i
want to go play mario maker so i'll see
you guys later hopefully i can post some
mario maker videos if i don't post any
it's probably because i'm sitting around
playing hope you guys have a great
weekend i'll see you bye do you care
you don't like when i play video games
because that means no attention for you